Spain lives
1 limiting situation as regards housing,
entire families that are
expelled from their lifelong neighborhoods,
youths sentenced to share apartment and refrigerator shelves
with reflections
for years,
prohibitive rents
in the main cities of the country,
abusive taxes
that hinder the acquisition of first home
to the most affordable rents,
real estate speculation,
public administrations
that prevent the expansion of buildable area,
occupation,
evictions of vulnerable families
no housing alternative
and 1 highly harmful housing law
which has raised prices and brought out
of the rental market
those who have the least.
Homeless,
homeless,
there are no life projects,
no families,
there are no strong links,
there is no roots,
there is no material welfare,
there is no future.
In this situation of residential financing crisis
for millions of people,
from the Vox parliamentary group
we have registered
1 initiative to increase
the social housing stock in our country.
Currently
only 2.5% of primary housing units in Spain
are social housing,
1 figure found
well below the European 2nd,
which currently stands at 9.3%.
However,
this situation has not always been the case.
Protected housing construction in 1985,
for example,
it exceeded 50 percent.
Spain needs around 2 million homes.
To meet the demand,
affordable rental.
It is necessary to promote 1 construction policy
determined and ambitious.
To address the lack of public housing in Spain.
We must ensure that young people and families
Spanish women can access 1 decent home,
only those who have insurance,
1 roof and some walls
can be truly free